wir alle machen fehler irren ist
menschlich und manche sagen sogar dass
uns erst unsere fehler wirklich zu dem
machen was wir sind aber es gibt
situationen in denen solche fehler nicht
vorkommen da gibt es keine toleranz
grenze oder punkte für guten einsatz da
zählt nur perfektion gut dass wir dafür
computer erfunden haben oder kalt
methodisch perfekt computer rechnen brav
mit ihren nullen und einsen und machen
keine fehler oder
leider falsch zumindest im bereich
machen computer sogar eine menge fehler
und die haben teils katastrophale
konsequenzen wie künstliche intelligenz
menschen diskriminiert wer wirklich
schuld daran ist und wie wir diese
probleme lösen können das erfahrt ihr
jetzt
[Musik]
es besteht die gefahr dass ein mensch
sich hinter der entscheidung vor allem
für mich oder programm versteckt und
damit aus der verantwortung zieht
[Musik]
ich habe papa
das hier ist die dritte folge unserer
videoserie über kg in zusammenarbeit mit
dem max planck institut für intelligente
systeme in tübingen falls sie die ersten
beiden folgen über generativen modelle
und über kausalität noch nicht gesehen
habt dann solltet ihr das für dieses
video hier auf jeden fall nachholen da
wie dort quasi die basis gelegt haben
und in diesem video hier auf einige
konzepte und beispiele aus diesen beiden
folgen zurückgreifen werden für diese
und für die nächste folge sind wir
übrigens natürlich unter einhaltung
aller sicherheitsmaßnahmen nach tübingen
ans max-planck-institut gefahren dort
sprechen wir auch heute wieder mit
annika buchholz die sich hier als
forschungs koordinatorin mit
verschiedenen aspekten des maschinellen
lernens beschäftigt ok im letzten video
haben wir ja schon über das beispiel der
criminal risk assessment algorithms in
den usa gesprochen hier werden maschinen
learning algorithmen eingesetzt um das
risiko zu berechnen dass ein straftäter
rückfällig wird das ergebnis war aber
leider dass menschen die jung sind oder
eine schwarze hautfarbe haben unter
diesem system längere freiheitsstrafen
bekommen das problem ist aber nicht das
mathematische modell oder der
algorithmus sondern in den trainings
daten die daten basieren auf
entscheidungen von menschen in den
vergangenen jahren und alle menschen
haben vorurteile und die spiegeln sich
in einem bei es wieder in diesem fall
geben richterinnen und richter menschen
mit schwarzer hautfarbe längere
freiheitsstrafen und das spiegelt sich
dann natürlich auch in dem algorithmus
wieder genau der algorithmus selber das
was umgangssprachlich künstliche
intelligenz genannt wird ist nicht mehr
als eine mathematische formel manche von
euch haben in den kommentaren unter dem
letzten video auch von excel-tabellen
mit vielen daten oder einem dynamischen
regelwerk gesprochen wichtig ist nur
künstliche intelligenz ist kein
eigenständiges denkendes wesen sondern
tut nur das was wir ihr beibringen und
wenn wir ihre daten geben die gegenüber
der realität verschoben sind dann wird
die ki diese verschiebung auch lernen
das nennt man dann einen bayers eine
verschiebung der statistischen
verteilung der daten etwas
umgangssprachlicher wird in der branche
auch gerne bobic in garwitz out gesagt
wenn man dem algorithmus schlechte daten
gibt dann muss man sich nicht wundern
dass diese auch schlechte ergebnisse
ausspuckt und schlechte daten sind
leider schnell produziert oft von uns
selber denn wir menschen sind alles
andere als objektiv fair oder perfekt
wir urteilen schnell und nutzen dabei
auch vorurteile das ermöglicht uns in
einer hochkomplexen welt schnell und
effizient entscheidungen zu treffen für
unser überleben ist das durchaus
praktisch kommt aber auch mit störenden
nebeneffekten zum beispiel dass wir
diskriminieren und unsere entscheidungen
ungerecht sein können wenn wir also
menschengemachte daten zum training
eines algorithmus verwenden dann kann es
schnell passieren dass der perfekte
computer unsere menschlichen fehler
übernimmt und wenn wir menschen dann
nicht aufpassen und auf basis des
objektiven computers entscheidungen
treffen nun dann passiert eben so was
wie in den usa aber dieses problem kann
auch weniger dramatisch sein als ins
gefängnis gehen zu müssen eine studie
des mrt media lab hat 2018
herausgefunden dass verschiedene
gesichtserkennungssoftware es nur
maximal 0,8 prozent derzeit einen fehler
machen allerdings nur wenn du ein weißer
mann bist beim schwarzen frauen zum
beispiel fällt die trefferquote des
algorithmus und dieser kann die personen
auf einmal in bis zu 34 57 prozent der
fälle nicht mehr erkennen das problem in
diesem fall ist aber nicht alles also
ein vorurteil sondern schlichtweg zu
wenig trainingsdaten für bestimmte
demografie wenn die entwicklerinnen und
entwickler ein trainingsdaten zeit
genutzt haben in dem hauptsächlich
fangen wir weiße männer vertreten waren
aber sehr wenig schwarze frauen dann
konnte der algorithmus deutlich besser
lernen die weiße männer aussehen und
nicht ich war zu frauen und genau das
ist der fall laut einer weiteren studie
von joy berlin ii befinden sich in
vielen trainings datensätzen zu über 80
prozent weiße menschen und weniger als
ein viertel sind frauen und das problem
kann aber einfach lösen indem man das
trainings hat erweitert und dem
algorithmus also einfach noch mehr daten
von zum beispiel schwarze frauen zu
füttert und dann kann er diese genauso
gut eben wenn wir unsere
gesichtserkennungssoftware kaum mit
bildern von menschen mit dunkler
hautfarbe füttern dann ist ja auch
irgendwo klar dass die software dort
weniger gut funktioniert denn sie hatte
einfach weniger möglichkeit zu lernen
wie zum beispiel ein schwarzes gesicht
aussieht und das führt zu einer
unsicherheit in den vorhersagen man sagt
auch der algorithmus hat dann eine
höhere varianz der anderen seite kann
man software eben nicht für alle und
jeden perfekt machen minderheiten werden
im zweifel einfach seltener fotografiert
und somit auch seltener einen
trainingsdaten sets vertreten sein
trotzdem sollten wir alles daran setzen
diesen problemen bewusst
entgegenzuwirken trainings datensätze
sollten immer möglichst umfangreich sein
vereinfacht gesagt fotografiert mehr
people of colour und mehr frauen
eigentlich recht easy aber es geht nicht
immer nur um diskriminierungen aufgrund
von hautfarbe oder geschlecht das kann
auch passieren dass zum beispiel seltene
krankheiten von einer medizinischen ki
schnell übersehen werden weil sie in den
trainings daten nicht oft vorkommen oder
das stimmen mit dialekt nicht so gut
erkannt werden weil im daten z immer
hochdeutsch gesprochen wurde neben
besseren daten helfen hier auch methoden
um die verallgemeinerung zu verbessern
zum beispiel durch forschung im bereich
kausalität wenn der algorithmus wirklich
versteht was ein gesicht ist dann sind
etwa zieht alter geschlecht alles andere
völlig irrelevant wie das genau
funktioniert das haben wir schon in der
zweiten folge unserer serie hier
diskutiert aber immer löst das unsere
probleme leider auch nicht wie wir schon
gesehen haben gibt es aber ja auch den
fall dass in den daten and byers ist und
das ist ein sehr schwieriges problem
denn in dem fall wollen wir aus den
daten etwas lernen dass sie gar nicht
repräsentieren sondern eine bereinigte
also eine korrigierte version davon und
im bereich fairness wird an methoden
vorschlag erarbeitet die eben dieses
problem problem zu lösen welche methoden
das sind das erklärt sich am besten an
einem beispiel aus der echten welt
nämlich bewerbungen viele unternehmen
kriegen hunderte oder sogar tausende
bewerbungen auf eine einzelne
arbeitsstelle und müssen aus diesem
riesigen pool dann eine person
herausfiltern die den job bekommt in der
klassischen welt entscheidet darüber
dann tatsächlich oft der zufall man
guckt zum beispiel die person aus der
abteilung in ihr e mail postfach
wenn deine bewerbung gerade in dieser
minute ganz oben weil du deine mail
genau zur richtigen zeit abgeschickt
hast dann kann das schon ausreichen um
zu einem gespräch eingeladen zu werden
außerdem spielt auch der menschliche bei
es immer eine große rolle menschen
stellen sich zum beispiel gerne selber
ein sie bevorzugen kandidatinnen oder
kandidaten die ihnen selber in alter
geschlecht oder herkunft ähnlich sind
dieser letzte effekt ist alles andere
als optimal denn er verstärkt bestehen
größtenteils weiße und männliche
strukturen diverse teams bestehend aus
personen mit unterschiedlichem alter
background und geschlecht performen aber
nachweislich besser die guten
nachrichten sind das maschinen learning
algorithmen hier tatsächlich helfen
können wenn man aufpasst verstehen
lernen kann aber auch die menschlichen
weißes übernehmen verstärken und alles
sogar noch schlimmer machen ein beispiel
amazon hat 2014 angefangen an einem
algorithmus zu arbeiten die aus einem
großen haufen kandidatinnen und
kandidaten die besten auswählen soll
tatsächlich sogar mit einem fünf sterne
system sowie auf der amazon website
trainiert wurde der algorithmus aber mit
bewerbungen der letzten jahre und das
waren größtenteils bewerbungen von
weißen männern eine demografie die in
der tech-branche überrepräsentiert ist
und so hat der algorithmus begonnen
automatisch bewerbungen aus dieser
demographie zu bevorzugen und weitere
weiße männer vorgeschlagen okay soweit
so schlecht aber ich möchte eines noch
mal betonen weil es unglaublich wichtig
ist das problem war nicht dass der
algorithmus von möglicherweise
sexistischen weißen männern geschrieben
wurde die programmierer des teams haben
vermutlich einen guten algorithmus
geschrieben und wollten wirklich die
besten kandidatinnen und kandidaten
finden das problem waren die
zugrundeliegenden daten mit denen
trainiert wurde ok einige von euch
werden jetzt sicherlich auf eine
wirklich schlaue idee kommen wieso
verschweigen wir dem algorithmus nicht
einfach welches geschlecht eine
bewerberin oder ein bewerber hat diese
daten können wir einfach aus den
bewerbungen herausnehmen bevor wir diese
analysieren lassen nun auf dieselbe idee
sind auch die programmierer von amazon
gekommen und dabei auf etwas
interessantes zu stoßen wenn man
sensitive variablen wie das geschlecht
oder die herkunft einer person aus den
daten entfernt dann findet das programm
fast immer eine möglichkeit trotzdem an
diese informationen heranzukommen
wie geht das nun der vorname zum
beispiel lässt oft sehr einfach auf das
geschlecht einer person zurück schließen
eigentlich logisch und der geburtsort
verehrt manchmal einen
migrationshintergrund solche größen oder
eigenschaften die in direktem einfluss
einer sensitiven variable stehen nennt
man auch proxys aber selbst wenn wir
alle proxies auch noch entfernen
korrelieren immer noch unglaublich viele
andere werte miteinander der wohnort die
ausbildungs fächer und sogar die hobbys
zum beispiel korrelieren mit der
herkunft und dem sozialen status einer
person hierzu eine spannende anekdoten
ich habe vor einiger zeit mit einem
befreundeten youtuber gesprochen der
längere zeit für ein unternehmen
gearbeitet hat das mit hilfe von
maschinen learning bewerbungen sortiert
und er hat mir erzählt dass der begriff
skifahren bei den hobbys eines
lebenslaufes stark damit korrigiert
welcher hautfarbe jemand hat anscheinend
fahren people of colour nicht so oft ski
oder geben es zumindest in ihrem
lebenslauf seltener als hobby an ihr
merkt es ist quasi unmöglich variablen
wie das geschlecht oder die hautfarbe zu
verstecken alles in unserem leben ist
miteinander verbunden und in unseren
daten versteckt ganz besonders deutlich
in den proxies wir können diese praxis
aber nutzen um den effekt der
diskriminierung zu berechnen und dafür
zu korrigieren wir haben ja schon mal
über kausalität gesprochen und hier
können wir das nutzen um eine
intervention auf dem proxy zu machen das
bedeutet also ein experiment zb nehmen
wir 20 mal die gleiche bewerbung wird
verschiedenen namen und schickt nie ein
und wenn wir dann sehen dass zum
beispiel jemand mit einem arabisch
klingenden namen 30 prozent weniger
eingeladen wird dann können wir diese
bewerbung mit einem entsprechenden
faktor pusten es gibt doch die methode
der demographischen parität das bedeutet
dass man explizit vorgibt welche
eigenschaften wie zum beispiel hautfarbe
oder geschlecht für eine entscheidung
irrelevant sein sollen und bizarrerweise
teilt man dann die bewerberinnen und
bewerber in genau diese kategorien ein
und wählt innerhalb der einzelnen
kategorien aus und so ist sichergestellt
dass diese eigenschaften das ergebnis
nicht beeinflussen weil eben immer nur
in der einzelnen kategorie entschieden
wird mit diesem mit weiteren ansätzen
versucht man im bereich fairness
ungerechtigkeiten also bestehenden bei
es in den daten zu korrigieren
diese methoden sind viel arbeit und
nicht immer einfach umzusetzen aber es
lohnt sich denn wenn algorithmen einmal
ordentlich und ohne ball trainiert sind
sollten sie fairere entscheidungen
treffen als wir menschen
[Musik]
klassisch geschriebene computerprogramme
also nicht ki folgen immer einer klaren
logik sie sind wie ein kochrezept es
gibt regeln die vom computer dann auch
genauso befolgt werden und wenn man die
programmiersprache beherrscht dann kann
man immer in den code hineinkopieren
was genau an welcher stelle passiert
aber bei maschinellem lernen ist das
anders basierend auf daten nennt man
eigenschaften oder statistische
verteilung und diese kann man sich nicht
einfach mal angucken das heißt man kann
nicht so leicht nachvollziehen wir jetzt
bestimmte klassifizierung vollzogen
wurden oder entscheidung getroffen
wurden und deshalb ist es so interessant
an erklärbarer ki zu forschen wenn das
team methoden die einen blick in die
blackbox ermöglichen und uns damit
helfen können eben diese entscheidung
nachzuvollziehen und interpretierbar zu
machen aber wie funktioniert das ich
dachte ki ist eben genau das eine black
box in die man nicht hineinschauen kann
nun das stimmt auch allerdings gibt es
einige methoden mit denen man zumindest
nachvollziehen kann welche faktoren bei
entscheidungen eine rolle spielen und
die methode die ich am verständlichsten
finde ist die der moving box stellt euch
vor wir haben einen algorithmus der
tiere klassifizieren kann wir geben ein
bild eines tieres rein und heraus kommt
ein label beziehungsweise um genau zu
sein die wahrscheinlichkeiten für alle
label oft wird dann einfach das label
mit der höchsten wahrscheinlichkeit als
antwort ausgegeben jetzt haben wir aber
das problem dass kühe am strand
komischerweise immer als hunde
klassifiziert werden woran kann das
liegen mit hilfe einer box können wir
einzelne elemente des bildes verdecken
und so herausfinden ob das etwas an den
wahrscheinlichkeiten ändert wenn wir zum
beispiel die komplette crew abdecken
kommt weiterhin hund dabei heraus das
ist nicht gut denn das zeigt dass der
algorithmus bei seiner entscheidung gar
nicht auf das tier achtet wenn wir die
box stück für stück über das bild
bewegen und aber die
wahrscheinlichkeiten beobachten dann
können wir herausfinden welche stellen
im bild welchen einfluss auf die
entscheidung haben daher der name moving
box heraus kommen eine menge werte die
wir in einem app übertragen können und
der algorithmus achtet nur auf den
hintergrund hunde werden gerne beim
spielen am strand fotografiert kühl
wiederum sind selten am strand zu finden
und der algorithmus hat nur die
korrelation hund strand gelernt gut die
meisten methoden im bereich der
erklärbaren ki sind deutlich komplexer
als die mailbox aber ich finde sie wie
gesagt ziemlich anschaulich aber was hat
das jetzt mit fairness zu tun es wäre
sehr hilfreich wenn die entscheidung in
einer ki begründet und contra faktische
fragen beantwortet werden könnten und
das geht zum beispiel mit bewerbungen
warum wurde ich nicht zum
bewerbungsgespräch eingeladen eine
berechtigte frage wie viele
interessieren dürfte nur wenn ich weiß
woran es lag kann ich mich aufs nächste
mal verbessern indem man simuliert wie
deine bewerbung sich gemacht hätte wenn
du zum beispiel eine bessere
abschlussnote oder einen höheren
assessment centers chor gehabt hättest
dann kann man sehen welche variablen das
ergebnis am meisten bewegen und jetzt
könnt ihr zum beispiel herauskommen dass
du vor allem deine programmierkenntnisse
verbessern müsste ist und vielleicht
noch etwas besser in englisch werden
solltest um für seinen zukünftigen
arbeitgeber interessant zu sein cool
falls allerdings herauskommt dass eine
variable wie das geschlecht oder die
herkunft einen einfluss auf das ergebnis
hat dann weiß die firma dass das
programm murks ist all diese dinge wie
man contra faktische fragen beantworten
kann und wie man diese nutzen kann um
entscheidungen von maschinen learning
algorithmen nachvollziehbar zu machen
werden übrigens aktuell am mpi in
tübingen erforscht und eine sache sollte
man auch unbedingt erwähnen natürlich
könnte auch ein perfekter algorithmus
nicht immer entscheiden wer die beste
person für einen job ist mit nur
begrenzten informationen wie sie eben in
einer bewerbung drin sind aus über
tausend menschen einen auszuwählen ist
von vorneherein ein kompromiss menschen
auf zahlen zu reduzieren das sowieso
nicht der weg den ich wählen würde aber
wir sehen ja leider dass das auch ohne
machine learning in vielen branchen
schon lange es ist mit kann man
zumindest versuchen die bestehenden
weise zu reduzieren und den
auswahlprozess für möglichst viele leute
möglichst fair zu machen auch wenn das
nie zu 100 prozent gelingen kann
annika wo stehen wir aktuell bei ferrari
und wo bewegen uns in deinen augen in
den nächsten jahren hin in der praxis
kann man kann natürlich noch viel mehr
einsetzen und im moment passiert und ich
denke das wird in den nächsten jahren
noch kommen und dann ist es sehr wichtig
dass die methoden im bereich verden ist
auch wirklich zum einsatz kommen und wir
auf der anderen seite aber auch nie
vergessen dass die objektivität dieser
programme an ihre grenzen stößt es
besteht die gefahr dass ein mensch sich
hinter der entscheidung von einem
computerprogramm versteckt und damit aus
der verantwortung zieht und da müssen
einfach aufpassen dass wir damit nicht
diskriminierung systematisch akzeptieren
oder in unsere programme einbauen und
uns nie aus der verantwortung ziehen
sondern immer wieder kritisch die
entscheidung der algorithmen
hinterfragen so wie wir auch unsere
eigenen entscheidungen immer kritischer
fragen das sehe ich genauso machine
learning beziehungsweise künstliche
intelligenz ist eben nicht intelligent
sondern nur ein werkzeug ein werkzeug
das uns menschen helfen kann wichtige
probleme zu lösen aber auch ein werkzeug
das nach hinten losgehen kann wenn wir
nicht vorsichtig damit umgehen
trotzdem solltet ihr jetzt nicht aus
diesem video heraus gehen und denken
dass kein reines risiko ist und wir das
ganze besser lassen sollten gute
maschinen learning algorithmen also
solche die ohne biss in den daten oder
sogar mit zu wenig daten trainiert
wurden ermöglichen es fairere
entscheidungen zu treffen und das ist es
auf jeden fall wert weiter verfolgt und
erforscht zu werden in der nächsten
folge unserer karriere widmen wir uns
dem vielleicht spannendsten thema dem
reinforced mit learning können maschinen
learning algorithmen so lernen wie wir
menschen von kindesbeinen an unsere
umwelt erforschen wir haben uns einen
selbstlernenden roboter angeschaut und
dürfen einen blick in die
experimentierwerkstatt des mpi
intelligente systeme werfen dieses video
kommt in einem monat hier auf doktor
watson bis dahin wie immer vielen dank
fürs zuschauen danke an annika für das
super spannende und sehr
aufschlussreiche interview und bis zum
nächsten mal bleibt
neugierig